oh my rocks are very brief betters about
these matters so mission being they also
say that I can write so as I say
somewhere in a part of my book widely
ridiculed
there's nothing but fermions and bosons
that's what reality is composed of um
and that I think is why Sean asked me to
start today well but I don't think that
we should trouble ourselves discussing
the details of particle physics
especially the presence of Steven
Weinberg um I certainly don't hold that
physics is bottomed out and press it
won't ever bottom out in say super
string theory or some equally
fundamental way of reconciling quality
naturalism and our view of the nature of
reality doesn't require us to take sides
on matters of the frontiers of physics
all it requires I think is two features
of physics which are fixed and unlikely
and I mean that with very great
confidence to be changed in the
subsequent development of physics no
matter where it goes and they have been
fixed in physics for a very long time
and those two features of physical
theory are its resolute denial of
teleology of any kind actually I thought
that was a word that would be common
coin around the table but I said if the
nice physics has no role for and in fact
as shown there is not in the universe
any kind of either backward causation
from the future pulling events
in some trajectory or any imminent
causation of that involves some kind of
our representation of what the future is
like and which organizes things in order
to attain that whether it's God or
something inside of nature imminent or
imminent so the denial of purpose goal
and it seems to me a feature that
physics has maintained ever since Newton
and is unlikely ever to be removed from
physics that no successor theory to the
succession of theories that have been
advanced since Newton is likely to
include any scope for such causal
processes in the dynamics is it
nevertheless useful to talk about
emergent phenomena in the world as if
they are newly logical like the neck of
the giraffe is observer purpose right so
I might say we can certainly help
ourselves to purpose of teleological
functional vocabulary but in doing so we
understand that we are engaging in a
somewhat misleading set of metaphors in
the way of course that well that
evolutionary biologists do when they
talk about design problems without any
commitment whatsoever to designers or to
any process in nature that could
probably properly be called designing um
so in that sense we're allowed to help
ourselves do it but if we took that
matter if we took that lingo seriously
there'd be no difference between your
Tony and mechanics and Aristotelian
mechanics and there's a big difference
well and the second thing that I think
physics has made a fixed point for all
of the other disciplines is the second
law of thermodynamics and everything
that happens in the universe had better
be not just compatible with the second
law of thermodynamics
but I'll be driven by the second law
because that is the source of all the
asymmetry
in cosmos um so yes all the time it's
symmetry um and I think there's no other
exhibitors besides of your time these
symmetries are what is produced by the
time eight symmetries um so this leap
brings me to the matter that will of
course be touched upon this afternoon
and probably regularly through the rest
of the weekend and in which I will be in
the snarling course which is even
wondered and that is reductionism ok
reductionism and here I'm gonna use some
jargon is a metaphysical thesis um it
says basically that there's no downward
causation and that physical is causally
closed that is that everything that
happens is a matter of causes and
effects to be understood at their
fundamental level in physics um that
insofar as there appears to be anything
like the downward causation or
emergentism those appearances reflect
temporary ignorance and that explanatory
autonomy of higher levels of disciplines
that explain phenomena at higher levels
of organization and physics of is an
epistemic thesis the explanatory
autonomy of these disciplines and
epistemic thesis and not a metaphysical
thesis and it reflects human cognitive
limitations and human cognitive
interests and no fundamental facts about
the organization of reality and I want
to stop there because I put enough
hostages to fortune on the table that we
could easily spend the rest of the
weekend on this agenda
you